One of the most important parts
of making high quality software.
Is rigorous testing.
Simply typing in test values into
a function won't get us very far.
So to do real testing on large scale,
tests need to be automated.
There are many types of tests, but
broadly tests fall
into one of two camps.
Unit tests and Integration tests.
Unit tests test individual classes or
methods in isolation.
Whereas Integration tests, test your
code in conjunction with some other
systems, libraries, or environments.
In addition to writing tests, we want to
automate the execution of our tests,
more importantly, we want to integrate
test execution into our build process.
The benefit of this is we can now
ensure that our tests are run
when our application is built, ensuring
that every change to our code is tested,
reducing the likelihood of unknowingly
introducing bugs into our software.
We won't get into the specifics
of how to write good tests, but
I hope I've convinced you on
the importance of testing.
Let's check out how can help us
easily automate our testing.